good afternoon
my name is dave fulgerson and i serve as
nevada's emergency manager and homeland
security chief
thank you all for being here with us
today
today we are wrapping up
our get out the vaccine efforts and our
partners with fema are moving on to
their next mission but as you're here as
you will hear today we're not wrapping
up our efforts to connect more nevadans
to the coven 19 vaccines
from the onset of this pandemic governor
syslak has helped ensured that the state
is using every resource at our disposal
to respond to covet 19
and that includes working with their
federal partners like fema
when the white house first announced the
option to have surge teams help augment
state efforts the governor's teammate
called me immediately to find out how to
get more boots on the ground in our
silver state
his leadership along with a history of
partnership between the nevada division
of emergency management and our federal
partners in fema is the reason why we
are one of the first states with a surge
team on the ground
at this time i'd like to introduce
governor steve syslock
thank you chief folkerson i appreciate
that i'm grateful for your continued
service to the state of nevada
whether that was helping with our
combating wildfires in northern nevada
or your work helping lead the covid 19
response across the entire state
as chief fulgerson mentioned we
officially made the request of the
federal government for additional
support in the form of fema surge teams
back on july 1st
in just about two weeks we had teams
from fema on the ground in silver state
working closely with chief fulgerson's
team at dem
leaders from our department of health
and human services and local partners
like the southern nevada health district
together
these teams quickly identified zip codes
in southern nevada with low vaccination
rates in high rates of infection
as targeted neighborhoods
leveraging partnerships with community
organizations
organizations like imminence nevada and
mi familia vota
teams immediately got to work on direct
and targeted outreach in those zip codes
since july
those teams have worked to canvas 21
separate zip codes in southern nevada
they've supported more than 280 outreach
and vaccination events and distributed
more than 300 000 pieces of literature
and materials in southern nevada
i am so grateful to the federal
government for making these fema teams
available and accessible to our state
and i'm even more grateful
to the organizations in nevada that
stepped up to help the surge teams
accomplish their mission
in the last few months in clark county
and across the state of nevada we have
made incredible progress in our fight
against covet 19.
our case race and positivity rates are
dropping rapidly
and we are seeing more nevadans
vaccinated every single night
the efforts of fema and the efforts
across the state of nevada are why we
are seeing this happen
statewide
now this is statewide our positivity
rate is down to 8.5
white pine pershing and clark have the
lowest positivity rates right now at 2.9
percent 5.6 percent and 6.7 percent
percent respectively
unfortunately we have some counties that
still have very high positivity rates
that we need to continue to work on
esmerelda
elko and lander
all have high positivity rates over 20
percent
that's too many nevadans who are testing
positive for
covid19 statewide
63 of the eligible population 12 and
older has chosen to initiate vaccination
against covet 19
and almost 55 percent of the eligible
population over age 12 is fully
vaccinated
washoe clark washoe carson and clark
have the top three vaccination rates in
the county by county with 70 percent 69
percent and 63 for clark of the
population who have started the
vaccination
process
with douglas not too far behind at 60
percent
again we have some counties in the state
that we need to do more to educate our
fellow nevadans about the importance of
vaccination
only 21
21 of the residents in story county have
initiated vaccination process
only 32 percent in eureka county
and we have low rates in lander and
lincoln as well
please help protect yourselves your
family your community and our economy
by getting vaccinated against covet 19.
it's a simple shot
that can help keep us protected and keep
our economy open
at this time i'd like to introduce
sharon luce who served as incident
commander for the nevada division of
emergency management to talk more about
the work accomplished since july
sharon
thank you governor sisilak without your
leadership this mission could not have
been a success
it was my honor to work alongside so
many dedicated employees and volunteers
in southern nevada since july
to help increase our outreach and
education efforts in southern nevada and
to help connect more nevadans to the
covet-19 vaccine
i wanted to take a few moments to
highlight some of our success
we've been able to keep track of
vaccination rates and zip codes that
were targeted for outreach and we've
seen tremendous success
we have this information available as
printouts for those in the room in a
copy of these materials will be
distributed after today's events
i wanted to start with the top four
zip codes where we saw an increase in
vaccination rates
i want to briefly highlight one but we
have maps and handouts that highlight
all the progress
in
89030 which is in north las vegas we saw
a 22 percent change in all doses
administered and a 21 percent change in
first doses administered
that means 21 more of the nevadans in
that zip code chose to protect
themselves from covid during this
mission
we were also able to compare areas of
clark county where we did targeted
outreach to areas that we did not do
targeted outreach
and we saw an average difference of two
percent in both all doses administered
and first doses administered
we have made tremendous progress in a
relatively short period of time i again
want to thank governor susilak for his
leadership
our state agencies the southern nevada
health district and our volunteer
organizations for their hard work at
this time i'd like to turn it over to
robert pessipain from fema to say a few
words
thank you sharon i'm robert pezpine i'm
the deputy federal recording officer for
the covet 19 event here in nevada in a
larger federal region
fema's mission is helping people i want
to thank governor sisolak and sharon
lutz for sharing their details on the
team effort here in southern nevada that
led to interactions with thousands of
individuals
at outreach events and think teams of
volunteers in neighborhoods that went to
the campus areas on doorsteps
these 101 interactions helped boost
vaccination rates and errors we focused
in areas
one of our bilingual volunteer
volunteers shared that his first
interaction with the las vegas las vegas
resident
was with someone who reminded him of his
abdullah his grandmother they connected
culturally and in spanish and she was
grateful for
the visit the encouragement and the vex
and
uh and to be vaccinated and the concern
and intention to help our community
over the course of the get out the
vaccine mission
there were more than 400 staff
volunteers from all over the country as
well as nearly 50 local volunteers
here in the clark county area
that contribute to the operation
a diverse staff with multilingual
capabilities contributed to the public
acceptance
made an impact in vulnerable communities
and change local perception and
importantly increase vaccination rates
greater awareness and increased
vaccination rates save lives
i want to give special thanks to
volunteers who spent long hot days
working to make this mission succeed
faith
based and community-based organizations
delivered critical helpers
peace corps and americorps volunteers
provided additional skill and compassion
the federal support
to the state of this locally executed
mission is concluding
but fema and federal partners remain
committed to nevada as we help work
together to protect people and
communities from covet 19.
at this time i'd like to return it back
over the governor's system act to make a
few closing remarks
thank you robert and all your colleagues
at fema who made nevada their home for
so long to help us in our efforts
again i want to express my thanks to
everyone who is involved in this process
and while fema surge teams are ending
their mission
we are still working to ensure nevadans
have access to the covid19 vaccine
again it is available it is a free and
it is effective
we are continuing to work with our local
health authorities like snhd and
volunteer organizations across the state
to make sure we reach nevadans wherever
they are
that includes working with the cdc
foundation to hire more support for our
efforts at no cost to our state
these are cdc foundation funded
positions who can bring more capacity
and support to the state
some of these new team members will be
working hand-in-hand with state agencies
like the department of health and human
services to provide extra support and
extra resources
i want to close with the reminder please
please
get your kovit 19 vaccine if you have
not already done so
if you're eligible for that for a
booster please get your booster shot you
can find a clinic near you at
nvcovetfighter.org
thank you very much and i'd be uh happy
to take a few questions if there are
any first
great
and do you see any point at which nevada
would impose
vaccination requirements such as those
that were just imposed by the city
of los angeles
uh i'm hopeful that the worst is behind
us but you never know with variants that
are coming forward i think that we've
got
making significant progress on the the
virus and as it relates to delta which
caused our last surge
i am not anticipating any more mandates
as you're talking about in l.a
i want to commend as i gave you the
figures earlier those in the state who
are helping us get the vaccination rates
up and positivity rates down
and encourage those who again who have
not been vaccinated
if not for yourself for your family for
your colleagues for our economy please
get the vaccine
dana in the back and then we'll come to
james hi governor do you have any grasp
of vaccination rates
among specific industries for instance
construction
anything like that i do not i don't know
if anybody has that i have anecdotal
stories from some of the industries when
when i meet with them as it relates to
the rates and do we have any of that
that's
that's self-reported data dana so we'll
have some of that anecdotally um so if
you want to email me we can pull from
specific industries
another question as you know a number of
correctional guards are upset about
having to get vaccinations
are you uh preparing for any sort of an
exodus
it is extremely important we have a
responsibility to protect our inmates
from covet
they're in a vulnerable position in a
very confined
setting as you're well aware
we tried to work with our correctional
officers and we're hopeful that they
will get the vaccine when they see
the benefit that it has i mean we hear
from families that have difficulty
getting in and seeing their family
members that are incarcerated
we're trying to find that balance but
it's important that we protect all of
these individuals while they're under
the custody
of nevada and
we're hopeful that we will have enough
cards get vaccinated
well you know i don't want to do a
uh
suppose that they're not going to my
my premise is that they are going to get
the vaccine and if they don't we're
going to have to take appropriate action
we'll come over to james and then sasha
thank you governor um
many of the bad ends have been asked
about the mass mandate can you
specifically provide an update to the
mass mandate are we on the road to
recovery in that element or
should we expect more
mandate remains the same that has been
in place they've got to be under uh
eight percent for two weeks in a row now
several as you heard of the counties are
under eight percent right now but you
also have to have your case number under
i think it was and fifty
uh
for a hundred thousand people for the
the weekly period we're falling far
short of that so the only way we can get
the mask mandate removed would you
believe me no one would like to remove
it more than i would would be to get
more people vaccinated and ultimately
have fewer cases
you mentioned vaccines
yeah we're seeing a lot of encouraging
signs we're seeing our hospitalization
rates are coming down you know our
positive cases are coming down which in
effect is making our numbers look better
there's a lag in all of these statistics
clearly uh but we're definitely on the
right
in terms of trajectory groups uh and
low-income areas in las vegas um i know
it's probably related to zip code but
have there been specific you know
targets within this program to target
specific minority groups that have lower
vaccination rates and has that been
successful governor i think sharon might
have some specific information and be
able to speak to some of that a little
bit okay and then i'll follow up
where you should go first
sorry megan i didn't want to interrupt
here
uh we're aware that in some of our
minority communities our communities of
color there's a little more resistance
or apprehension to getting vaccine that
was one of the things that the fema
surge teams did so well for us is
reaching into those communities and
hoping uh
to educate folks a little bit more we're
working with our
faith-based communities to get that word
out and we'll continue to do so as we
move forward
so
one of the maps that you see and that
will be in the handouts is this svi data
of las vegas
and so
the top six zip codes where we're seeing
low vaccination rates were were selected
and then the overlay that you're seeing
is the social vulnerability index which
is which is measurements like
racial and ethnic
minorities
social economic status those kinds of
things and so the darker blue the area
is
the more of those minority groups and
those that are socially vulnerable
are in the in the uh county and that was
the the information that we were going
off of and so all of the objectives that
we that we
put out there forget the vaccine for our
teams uh to do outreach uh were to
target those areas where we were seeing
those minority groups and other
social economic circumstances
great thanks
jacob from the indy hi governor so we
just obtained a copy of a letter from
blockchain ceo jeff burns withdrawing
the company from the innovation zones
committees and in it he says at the
state there was no state champions for
the concept are you disappointed in the
withdrawal
well you know economic diversification
continues to be a priority for me i'm
disappointed that uh jeff and blockchain
chose to go in a different direction
uh it was a proposal that was being
vetted through the committee that was
formed
but blockchains is going to make their
decision and the state
we talked about it during the last
session and we're going to wait and see
but moving forward we're continuing our
quest for economic diversification
all right thank you everyone for coming
out we will see you at the next one